- [Narrator] China has the
largest high-speed rail network
in the world,
spanning over 40,000 kilometers.
And of the 10 fastest trains in the world,
four are in China.
And China's busiest high-speed train,
the Beijing-Shanghai Rail,
runs 217 miles per hour.
The US, however, tells
a much different story.
Its high-speed rail system
spans 735 kilometers,
and its fastest train,
Amtrak's Acela Express,
goes just 150 miles per hour
and only for a few minutes
on part of the track.
Since 2008, China has rapidly built up
its high-speed rail network.
The US in that time
has had several high-speed rail projects
shelved or delayed.
Here's how the US has fallen behind China
in high-speed rail technology.
One key difference
between the US and China
has to do with the
tracks the trains run on.
- In the case of the US, as we can see,
a lot of the Northeast Corridors
are based on hundreds
years of the old tracks.
There are also tunnels and
the curvatures and bridges
that are really owed
that cannot really allow the trains to run
at the faster speed.
- [Narrator] These tracks
were originally built
for freight and passenger trains
to use at the same time
so they have many points of
intersections and crossings,
and the Acela runs on this track.
But China has tracks that are
dedicated to high-speed rail.
- They are really required to
have a more smoother curves,
also they needed to have
more slower gradients,
and so that allow the trains
to run smoothly and safely.
- [Narrator] One of the
reasons trains in America
can't reach their top speeds
is because of how the tracks are designed.
- Even though the trains are
capable for Amtrak to run 186,
they'll never see more
than 160 miles per hour
because the infrastructure
is still being developed
and isn't quite there yet.
- [Narrator] It comes down
to curves on the tracks.
Many conventional
passenger trains in the US
only operate 10 to 15
miles per hour faster
than freight trains on the
curved portion of tracks.
But China built its high-speed
rail on elevated tracks,
traveling on what's called viaducts.
- So the tolerances in high-speed
are pretty precise,
pretty tightly defined,
and so the track and overhead
wires need to be designed
in a way to be able to
allow those higher speeds.
- [Narrator] There's also a difference
in where stations are located.
In China, stations for high-speed rails
are located in both suburban
and rural areas of the country,
whereas in the US,
stations are primarily
located in urban centers
like New York City,
Boston, and Washington, DC.
- When you're looking to identify
where a high-speed line should go,
it really starts with where
are the two population centers
you're trying to connect.
And the magic formula is
really find two city pairs
that have a minimum of 3
million people on either side
and a distance of about two to 500 miles.
- In order to achieve a higher speed,
definitely, a dedicated
passenger rail system
is more needed.
- [Narrator] Despite the fact
that the US has been slow
to develop high-speed rail,
railroads actually used to dominate
interstate transportation,
but that shifted during
the mid-20th century
when the Interstate
Highway System was born.
Since then, American history
has been littered with
high-speed rail plans
that never really took off.
- Automobile and air travel and car travel
has essentially become the
major modes of travel in the US.
To make that kind of behavior change,
that basically needs a lot of efforts
to help people understand
why this is a need to have another mode
and what are the benefits of that.
- [Narrator] China's
high-speed rail, however,
consistently had backing
from the government,
investing billions of dollars,
including initial partners
with foreign firms.
Contracts were awarded on the condition
that foreign companies assemble the trains
and also train Chinese engineers.
- So they're trying to understand
that the foreign technologies,
how it works,
but they're also trying to
make for certain innovations
on top of that.
- [Narrator] Eventually China developed
its own train manufacturing
company, the CRRC.
And now the CRRC
is one of the largest train
manufacturers in the world.
- In the case of China,
because it's a central government system,
so large infrastructure projects
like high-speed rail system
can be really developed
based on the kind of consistent plant.
- [Narrator] The US has
also had foreign companies
come to the country to develop
a high-speed rail network,
but it's been met with several challenges.
Take for example, Illinois.
Back in 2019, Nippon Sharyo of Japan
tried to build a high-speed
rail in the states.
However, the company struggled
to adapt designs to the US
and faced delays in getting new rail cars.
And changing administrations doesn't help.
California approved a plan in 2008
to build a high-speed rail network,
but the project has been delayed
because of a lack of funding
and inconsistent support.
- The train technology is already here.
What we're seeing right now in the US
at this specific moment in time
is not that dissimilar
to what was happening
in Europe in the 1970s
where there was initially a lot of concern
or objection about trying
to do something new.
And it wasn't until the first system
started to be put in place
and people saw the real promise
that high-speed was able to deliver on.
And then once the political
and public support was behind it,
it really took off and grew.
(gentle music)